you know I don't think we give enough
credit to the people that mistreated us
in our lives yes the people that
mistreated you betrayed you backstab you
said something negative about you maybe
a parent that left you in didn't you get
a father that left you and a mother that
didn't want to see you again
I don't think we give enough credit to
those people I think we give way too
much credit for motivation to the people
that we're very good to us and by the
way more power to the people that were
very good to us but motivation doesn't
come from there think about it this way
you know how many people have done
business plans with and they say I asked
mrs. so tell me what why are you
starting a business why are you doing
this oh because I want to return my mom
really six months later they're not
moving they quit their business they
shut it down what happened I thought you
really wanted to retire your mom no well
who's been nicer to you than your mom
nobody how come there's no motivation
I see a lot of people say I'm doing this
for my kids really yes hmm you're later
you come in late you're not running your
office you know your company shuts down
your office just then you go back to a
job what happened there didn't you love
your kids I love my kids
I've come in and created urgency for you
how come you two move faster
how come you to make you come to the
office early in the morning and compete
Oh work hard
doesn't mean you don't love your kids no
let me tell you something you you know
how many people I know their motivation
came because one person said you'll
never make it another person said you'll
never win without me or a dad left at
the age of seven never came back and
called back once he started winning you
know how many stories there's like that
our mother told the child you'll never
succeed in life those are the things
that moves people
it's very easy to say oh my gosh it's
only for the people I love so how it
works
it's and how it works you just made a
list of 50 names on what moved them none
of the main reasons of the people I made
a list of them moved them with the
people they love the most the motivation
for the people they loved the most was
in the top five or wasn't on number one
on the list
there was didn't create that urgency you
know I love my haters I can't say how
much I love them I'm very grateful for
them I'm not trying to give you one of
these rah-rah positive like sweet nice
oh my god she's just trying to be so no
no no let me take it believe me
let me tell you why I love them they
don't have any clue what kind of fire
they're created you know how many lists
of names I have what phrases and
sentences and things they said I have a
mall so this video isn't about me this
videos about you what are you doing it
for do you think it's just the people
you love maybe one of the reasons has it
moved you really really it's moved you
so you mean to tell me you've been
working 80 hours hundred hours every
week for the last 17 months no you
haven't
so it doesn't move you iPad you means it
to me I've got to work 80 to 100 hours a
week if something moves you no one can
stop you see I don't measure how many
hours I work a week but I know how many
hours I want a week
if people realize like how many hours
they put in it may scare some of the
people but there's a deeper motivation
they're deeper deeper motivation there
you got to figured out I used to think
it was like oh my gosh two people will
win you know perfect parents everything
solid no no no they don't have to tap
into the real motivation
do you have you
you figured out
[Music]
imagine like a source like imagine you
they go well and you strike oil like
somewhere in the middle-east type of oil
Texas oil Venezuela oil Alaska oil Sat
Dakota type of oil and it never stops
you know what I'm saying that's the kind
of motivation I'm talking about it never
stops
so stop discounting the people that
mistreated you stop discounting the
statements they made to you and realized
many of those people could be the reason
why you end up doing what you're doing
in your life that's big
[Music]
about very big let's make a list write
the phrases down and tell yourself I am
doing it for my kids I'm doing it for my
wife my husband my family my mom my dad
the people who love imma teach them to
do here's also these 10 pictures these
10 faces these 10 names and it's secret
and the you versus you and you say never
forget what my ex-boyfriend said this
never forget when my ex-girlfriend or
ex-wife or my ex-husband said this you
can't make it without me you will never
be anything in life and those are some
exciting words for such exciting words
people tell me my parents told me I can
make it they don't support me good let's
see what you're gonna do about it
good I'm glad you're getting some
rejection I'm glad you're getting some
pain I'm glad it bothers you a little
bit I hope it bothers I hope it keeps
you up at night I hope it makes you want
to do more just home I love you so much
baby where is the motivation on that I
love you so much baby I love you baby
baby baby baby baby baby baby baby
no that's fine we all need to be a lot
doing me wrong I'm not saying I don't
want to be liable Eve me I love it my
family my kids the people that matter to
me love me well you need morning them
even more than them so make the list Co
tops inators right now what they did
chill and every day throughout today
somehow remind yourself of those phrases
see what kind of feeling the crates for
you don't get angry get excited get
jacked up
it's visualize what happens when it
becomes a reality you have to say
anything the world's gonna know about it
when it becomes a reality is the best
kind believe me this guy best guy
natural highs are the best eyes anyways
hey I hope this message resonates with
you I hope you have to kill a week this
week take care bye bye
[Music]